remember that even in 2022 the david
pakman show continues to be sponsored
primarily by viewers and listeners
through the david pakman show membership
program i invite you to sign up
uh at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22.
that's and you have to say it that way
wow 22. all one word all lowercase and
you will get a discount that is uh
this type of thing they might outlaw
this if depending on who wins in
november they may outlaw this type of
discount sign up at joinpakman.com okay
am i ready to tell you how insane the
u.s coveted numbers are no why not well
we don't have the full numbers from the
last few days because of the new year's
holiday i can tell you that the numbers
have gone nuclear
or nuclear to quote certain people okay
you know former president bush
but we don't yet have the full numbers
but it's looking like real infections
real because a lot of people don't test
at all or you know all that stuff
we may be talking 1.5 to 1.8 million
covet infections a day in the u.s u.s
okay real number we will get to that the
question about this
insanely transmissible omicron variant
is
what will it do
and for how long
in terms of hospitalization and death
although if it's this contagious
the total burden
on society is going to go up because
it's so contagious you're still going to
get hospitalizations you're still going
to get deaths
if it is dramatically less deadly
as a percentage of cases of infections
it could very quickly accelerate our
progress
to the end of the pandemic phase which
will just go to the endemic phase one
place we are looking at very closely is
south africa because south africa was we
don't say it was the place it came from
but it was one of the earliest
countries
to
be very open about the data of the
number of people infected etc
we now have news from south africa south
africa says it has passed its fourth
wave of cases meaning they believe that
omicron is essentially done or ending in
south africa and it counts very few
added deaths now if you're saying but
david a lot of things are different here
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to that new york times the south
african government said thursday data
suggests the country has passed its
omicron peak without a major spike in
deaths offering cautious hope to other
countries grappling with the variant
some scientists were quick to forecast
the pattern elsewhere so let's look at
the numbers that we had um now as you
can see if you're watching you you can
see
this massive case spike i mean going
from about 300 cases a day
to 23 000 cases a day okay that's that's
almost uh
you know a 200x increase at 150 or
something like that increase in cases
but
their cases are now down something like
what's that 16 over 24 down about 66
percent
but deaths had a very modest spike
we don't not care about these deaths
they're still tragic
but when you see that cases went up what
150 to 200 times
and deaths went up from about 30 a day
to like 60 a day you say
that that's pretty notable that's pretty
notable now
why might it be different
in the united states or in other
countries there's a bunch of different
reasons first of all
during earlier waves
south africa had very low levels of
vaccination meaning that earlier waves
sort of burned through the population
large parts of the population
the beta variant which was not huge
outside of south africa
went through there that may provide
more um
sort of uh population protection to s
these are questions it may remember that
delta different lineage than omicron not
believed to provide not believed to
provide significant protection against
omicron omicron is based on an earlier
lineage it's split earlier so to speak
it's theorized that the beta variant
having burned through south africa
might make omicron particularly less
severe in south africa and we might not
have that we don't have that and it may
be notable in the united states that's
number one so we have to wait and see
number two
the south african population is much
younger than the united states five
percent of south africa's population is
65 plus
16 of the u.s population is 65 plus
that's very different so
if we have to guess right now
there's these two competing stories
it'll be insanely bad in the united
states or it'll be just like south
africa
the most likely scenario based on what
we have now because lower rate of
hospitalization is being observed in a
lot of different places is that it will
be worse in the u.s than in south africa
but it won't be nearly as bad on a on
the case rate basis
as earlier waves were
the other thing that's sort of important
to remember
is in the uk
even the rising hospitalization numbers
a ton of the people hospitalized with
kovid
are not hospitalized because of covid
when you test everyone who is in the
hospital and you have something so
contagious that could be 40 asymptomatic
you're going to find tons of people who
have it and are in the hospital for
something else they still count
so my view here is still cautious
optimism
and we're going to continue looking at
the numbers